there's one thing we all know about Juan
Williams it's that he's a die-hard
sports fan the Washington Nationals are
one of his true love's next to his wife
and kids of course so we decided to ship
him back to DC for behind-the-scenes
look at tonight's Major League Baseball
all-star game at Nationals Park Wan you
must feel like a kid in a candy store
there Larry you got it right so I sort
of ecstatic you know it's like that John
Fogerty song the Sun came out put me in
coach I'm ready to play I'm on the field
at Nationals Park you got to tell Greg I
ran into some San Francisco Giants Oh
Brandon Crawford but lack of the car
Iraqis just came over to say hello he's
a five fan folks oh look at that and you
know it's just been an extraordinary
time last night they had the homerun
Derby
you got to tell Jesse that reese hopkins
of the phillies put on a show but he
didn't Bryce Harper whatever price he
came back at the end in spectacular
fashion and had this place rocking like
I mean I'm a big fan I'm a season ticket
holder I haven't seen Nationals Park
Rock like that before
it was spectacular well I'm one I'm so
glad that you weren't here yesterday and
today because you would have just been
screaming about Trump I'm trying to be
as hip as Jesse but Jesse you're the
younger generation and by the way
yesterday I got to talk with the players
and Jesse they're younger than you
younger than 41 I have a question how
did Washington DC land this opportunity
to be the venue for this all-star game
well this is an interesting question
Dana because the learners who own the
team have been asking for some time and
they finally got it but the the problem
and this is so interesting it's just
like logistics and TV they couldn't get
the Convention Center and they needed
the convention center they have a huge
exhibit over there old
timers hall-of-famers you know
meet-and-greet sessions for fans and
they've got it this year and so it came
in but this is a brand new ballpark I
would say now about five years old and
so they've been angling to try to get it
and boy has the town responded
everything from the Library of Congress
to the Congress itself all really
putting on the show for Major League
Baseball
hey wine after the rain the field looks
soggy err that a truck drivers
Underpants I was curious
can you drink at the at the field yeah
you can you drink yeah can you drink it
there we're gonna dry I don't know I've
never been that drunk so here's the
thing here's the thing so Deb Cody who's
the producer from the five is with me we
got caught in the Nationals dugout and
all of a sudden it flooded Greg yeah it
flooded I mean we couldn't get out and
so they have to put chairs down like a
bridge so that we could walk out what
was hilarious but they had pumps they
brought out pumps and they looked like
you know squeaking with fear that
there's something was going to interfere
with the game the players are just
coming out now for batting practice but
it worked they drank it up well